>>
KAY: Hi, everyone, my name is Erik Kay. This
is Aaron Boodman. And we're really excited
to be here for launching Chrome Extensions
into beta after a year of hard work. So, 15
months ago when Chrome was first launched,
one of the first things we heard from our
users was asking us about extensions. And,
in fact, it's the oldest open issue in our
bug database, issue 18th. So, it got filed,
literally, minutes after we launched. And
FIT was soon filled with hundreds--a hundred
comments or more of people saying, “Yes,
plus 1, me too.” You know, all the really
helpful comments that, you know, that people
really want this. So, after it got a little
bit out of hand, we locked down the bug for
further comments and finally said, “Yes,
okay. We’re working on extensions.”
>> BOODMAN: Somebody commented in the times
since we opened this up.
>> KAY: Uh-oh. Well, so today, I'm glad to
say that we're finally marking the bug fixed.
So, when we announced that we were starting
it, we got a lot sort of surprise reactions
from people saying that, “Not only don't
you have extensions, but you haven't even
started them yet.” Like, and the reason
that reaction was there was because a lot
of pioneering work that Firefox and the Mozilla
community have done to really make extensions
to be unexpected feature for the browser.
So, it's now something that people demand
and people want in browsers. However, the
problem with extensions is that when you build
them, they really depend on all the lowest
level parts of the browser. So, when we were
developing Chrome before we launched, lots
of stuff was moving around. It was pretty
chaotic and it wasn't really a good place
for us to start building extensions. It wasn't
until we released, that things got a little
bit more stabilized, that we really had a
solid foundation to start building on. So,
one of the interesting side effects of waiting,
the way we did, was that we were open sourcing
public from day one. With that means is that
our very first design document about extensions
was published from the Internet directly.
It was about a year ago in November. And since
then, we've been continuing to publish updates
and examples and sample code and get feedback
from the community, which helped keep us on
the right track. One of the other interesting
side effects of this is that a lot of you
in the audience probably got much earlier
access to the code than you would have otherwise
gotten. And in fact, the first extension that
was written outside of Google was written
literally hours after we checked in the code
that enabled it. It's been really exciting
to work this closely with the community and
we're really excited to keep working that
way going forward. So, when we started designing
Chrome Extensions, how do we start? We started
with Chrome’s design principles and said,
“How can we make extensions that fit into
that?” Well, first, basically, we built
on the open Web. We worked hard to make them
Webby, this makes some fun and easy to develop.
People can use their existing skills and it
grows with the Web platform. We kept the UI
streamlined. Chrome is all about wrapping
powerful functionality and a streamlined user
interphase. We believe that a fast browser
enables richer set of applications than could
be done before, and keeps people more productive.
And that's especially important today because
we're all spending a lot more time in front
of our browsers. Not only are we spending
more time but we're doing lots of things at
same time. We got a lot of Tabs and Windows
opened. So, it's important that the browser
remains stable. You don't want it to crash
and lose all your work, and so it's important
that a single extension can't take down your
browser. Further today, we're doing many more
of our more sensitive activities online as
well, whether it's just email or paying bills
or doing your taxes. It's important that the
browser stays secure. So, an extension that's
insecure shouldn’t be able to compromise
this core security of the browser itself.
So, what are extensions anyway? Extensions
are just Zip files that are collections of
Web pages and their associated resources,
like, images and CSS files. So, if you remember
one thing from today's presentation, this
should be it. Extensions are just Web pages.
And a lot of really cool things fall out of
this as a result. First, extensions are really
easy to write. It's easy as writing a Web
page. If you're a Web developer, you get to
reuse all your existing skills and knowledge.
You can use all of the powerful tools that
you’re used to using to develop Web pages
to build extensions. You can also take advantage
of the largest developer community in the
world for any platform. The Web platform has
more developers than any other platform. On
top of that with Chrome, you can take advantage
of future looking technologies. Things that
are--that are--that normally wouldn’t necessarily
see as much of in the WildWeb, HTML5, Workers,
Canvas, video, Web sockets, things from WebKit,
CSS3, you know, reflections and gradients,
lots of cool stuff that we take for granted
on the Chrome team, but maybe you're out seeing
in the WildWeb. And you get to depend on having
lightning fast JavaScript in your browser
with V8.